i ain't really did no shows yet but
slob or am i not like on oh no you dig
i'm rapping with this my
phone
[Music]
what's up gq this is juicy j and these
are my essentials
[Music]
i keep a lot of shades in the studio
with me
everywhere i go because i switch shades
all the time
i started wearing shades back when i was
younger because i had a bad allergy
problem
so my eyes would get like crazy red and
they would puff up all the time when i
was younger
so i was like i'ma just start wearing
shades so i just started wearing shades
every time people see me i had shades on
because i was trying to hide my eyes
because they were so puffed up and you
know when i started smoking weed and
drinking alcohol after that man i need
to cover my eyes up man cause i'm
you know when you be talking to me
sometimes i might have my eyes closed
you know only only in studio sessions
only not in business meetings business
meetings
i'm sober's a month and if i'm kind of
high in a business meeting i'm coming
down from a high
i like these right here i call these my
dwayne weights
there's some um gucci's they need to be
clean but i'm just
in my dwyane ways because you know i did
a video with them
you know wherever you at you're in the
strip club you're trying to
shake that you got to let them up you
know darken that
darken the club so you okay all right
so i keep this black card everywhere i
go it never goes out of my sight
i sleep with it sometime if i need to
this car right here
is like ain't no limit you can spend
what you want to spend you can spend a
million dollars on it two million
dollars
just keep going you got to pay it back
now it's a credit card but you know you
can
it has no limit on it the slash away
slash away slash away all
well i know some crazy stuff i've done
which i shouldn't have done
off this card i spent like 3 500
on like alcohol i just put my card down
and saying man everything on me
man well i looked at that card just said
3500 i was like dana alcohol
this is a sp 1200 this is a classic drum
machine
this uh i make all my beats on this
well i wouldn't say all but just about
all
we got the old sounds i use you're
hearing them old three six mafia kicks
and snatch
it's coming from this back in my younger
days this this this drum machine
actually
took me to that next level make a lot of
good dope beats on it i made a bunch of
uh
beats for making the staggering on here
young doll
um everybody i've done production with
you know what i'm saying ti
something that a lot of rappers don't
carry around
checkbook it ain't nothing wrong with uh
walking around with cash
but you know it's like when you pay
somebody cash
either they sign a receipt which have
the time people don't have receipts
then i where's that money like how can i
write that off on my taxes and
keep track of that money you know with
this thing
you keep track of everything that goes
on
somebody working for you write them a
check in the memo you can write down you
know
what the job was for you know send it to
your accountant
get that right off on your taxes you
know i'm just trying to school you i
ain't trying to fool you
you did it's a good check if i write you
a check
they say look these these ain't no
basketballs man these just gonna always
go through
coral water i keep this in the studio
with me matter of fact i'll drink some
now
[Music]
so this is a good water um
because i invested money in it company
was sold to
carrick for like 500 million dollars i
got a piece of that i didn't get the
whole 500 million dollars i got a piece
of that
yeah every time you buy these i get a
check every time you buy dr pepper juicy
jake it's a chick
every time you buy anything from carrick
i get it check
to make a long story short
this is my um small crowd mask if i'm in
like a small
maybe like a 20 people i got this on
then when i'm around like a concert hall
of people
they got these big filters right here
got a nice little filter right here
strap on
protecting the face the eyes i mean like
this is one of a kind it's like some
stuff
call of duty you know
i travel with this bible all the time i
always put it in my bags i don't care
where i'm going
i got others if i got i got the gold
yard back right there
throwing the bible in there you know
what i'm saying if i'm traveling it
don't matter like wherever i'm at
like sometimes you may see me in the
studio there probably gonna be a bible
in that bag
seriously nine times out of ten it is i
trust in it you know what i'm saying
i always felt like it was good luck you
know
it's a hotel room uh bible for real
facts
yeah seriously but it don't matter where
it comes from you know what i'm saying
it don't matter where i come from you
know i'm saying it's always still a good
book
mcqueen this is wiz khalifa's gin it's
really good gin
i keep this on deck i drink this a lot
this gets the vibes going in the studio
you should try it it's really good um
it's smooth
if you're drinking water you can just
did that buzz just get to rise you know
juicy jb
come on you just got to you know i drink
it straight
sometimes we like a little ice sometimes
i just
you know but i don't just go crazy you
know i just sip
smoke a little bit listen to a bee sieve
smoke go in the booth like some flow
you know balancing myself through the
day you know
if i'm at home like watching a football
game or something a movie oh yeah i'm
[ __ ] you know what i'm saying why not
you only live once
these two
lysol and disinfectant wipes
you got to keep these in the studio
which you got to keep these
in your car you got to keep these just
got to keep these man you know
these guys try i was doing it before
but i'm doing it more now because i got
kids around the house so you know and
sometimes i have uh
just different people coming through
like you know working on the house and
different things not a lot but it's
different things so i had to make sure i
wiped out
so i keep like close to me at all times
like that you know
thank you gq it's your boy juicy j thank
you for checking out my essentials
hope to see you soon i have some more
stuff to show you